oh boy nous devons y aller maintenant nous n'avons qu'une
fenêtre de 30 secondes vous connaissez le plan bien
ce qu'il a sauté il a sauté hein d'
accord un pour tous
ce que ferait Vin Diesel pas de regrets pas
juste
vous pensez combien de types de mètres rapides
le troisième du  cinéma lava lava eh bien
vous ne voulez pas vraiment refaire ça,
ça ne marche généralement pas bien pour
vous les gars
où ça irait
merci quel est votre nom
non c'est quoi
non Stacey moans OH
Casey Jones Ninja Turtles de cinéma lava
lave hé les gars personne ne bouge ne bouge pas
il y a un rat géant là-bas ouais
nous l'avons vu ici avant que vous
sachiez qu'il n'y a qu'un seul moyen de se débarrasser de
je dois prendre une balle oh ouais allez-vous y aller Adam tu dois aller vite dois
allez fort hein crois en toi Casey Jones
t'a vu mon frère tu en as exactement trois pour
arriver à un ici quel rat géant un
nouveau gars Oh Stu Oh amour du cinéma Olivia
nous avons des bogeys dans le bus d'accord appuyez sur le
bouton quel plaisir il y a un  millions de
boutons numéro trois numéro trois trois
Oh
tu as de la compagnie Mikey c  lear d'accord les
nunchucks en flocons giganticus
disent bonjour à mon petit ami
ouais Mikey ces choses sont assez
géniales hein ouais assez génial Oh les
médecins ninja voyez-vous nommé un luffa vous avez de la
compagnie
Oh
ça va les gars
Oh les gars ils reviennent il est temps de
sortir  la poubelle
c'est comme ça que je roule c'est comme ça que tu roules
tout ce que je peux faire pour toi
Tortues Ninja du cinéma loofah